what is going on everybody and welcome
to a much-needed update to the deep
learning and Python with tensorflow as
well as now chaos tutorial it's been a
bit over two years since I did just a
basic deep learning video in Python and
since then a lot has changed it's now
much simpler to both like get into it
but then also just to work with deep
learning models so if you want to get
into the more nitty gritty details in
the lower-level tensorflow code you can
still check out the older video but if
you're just trying to get started with
deep learning that's not necessary
anymore because we have these nice
high-level api's like chaos that sit on
top of tensorflow and make it super
super simple so anybody can follow along
if you don't know anything about deep
learning that's totally fine we're going
to do a quick run-through of neural
networks also you're gonna want Python
3.6 at least as of the release of this
video hopefully very very soon
tensorflow will be supported on three
seven and later versions of Python just
happens to be the case right now it
isn't I think it's something to do with
the async changes I'm not really sure
anyways let's get into it starting with
an overview of how neural networks just
work alright to begin we need to have
some sort of balance between treating
neural networks like a total black box
that we just don't understand at all and
understanding every single detail to
them so I'm gonna show you guys what I
think is just the kind of bare essential
to understanding what's going on so a
neural network is going to consist of
the following things like what's the
goal of any machine learning model well
you've got some input so let's say X 1 X
2 X 3 and you're just trying to map
those inputs to some sort of output
let's say that output is determining
whether something is a dog or that
something is a cat so the output is
going to be two neurons in this case so
it's just boom two neurons now what we
want to do is is figure out how are we
going to map to those things we could
use a single hidden layer let's say
we're going to do some neurons here and
that's our first
hidden lair now what's gonna happen is
each of these X 1 X 2 and X 3 these are
gonna map to that hidden lair each of
the input data x' gets connected to each
of the neurons in that first hidden
layer and each of those connections has
its own unique weight now from here that
first hidden layer could then map and
connect to that output layer the problem
is if you did this the relationship
between x1 and dog or cat and all the
other ones those relationships would
only be linear relationships so if we're
looking to map and nonlinear
relationships which is probably going to
be the case in a complex question you
need to have two or more one hidden
layer means you just have a neural
network two or more hidden layers means
you have a quote-unquote deep neural
network so we'll add one more layer and
then we're gonna fully connect that one
two and then once that's fully connected
again all unique weights each of those
blue lines has a unique weight
associated with it and then that gets
mapped to the output and again each blue
line has a unique weight associated with
it so now what we're gonna do is talk
about what's happening on an individual
neuron level so again that neuron has
certain inputs coming to it it might be
the input layer X values or it could be
inputs coming from the other neurons so
we're gonna again we're gonna call the
inputs x1 x2 and x3 but just keep in
mind this could actually not be it might
not be your input data it might be data
coming from another neuron but
regardless that data's gonna come in and
we're just gonna get the sum of that
data so it's gonna come in and be summed
all together but remember we also have
those weights each of the inputs has a
unique weight that gets put you know
multiplied against the input data and
then we sum it together finally and this
is kind of where the artificial neural
network comes into play we have an
activation function and this activation
function is kind of meant to simulate a
neuron actually firing or not so you can
think of the activation function like on
a graph you know you got your X and your
Y and then a really basic activation
function would be like a step or
function so if X is
than a certain value boom we step up and
we have a value so let's say here this
is zero here the value is one so let's
say this is our x-axis 1 2 3 so if X you
know after being all the inputs are
multiplied by their weights sum together
if that value is let's say greater than
3 well then this activation function
returns a 1 but today we tend to use
more of a sigmoid activation function so
it's not going to be a 0 or 1 it's going
to be some sort of value between 0 and a
1 so instead we might actually return
like a point seven nine or something
like that so coming back to this neural
network here that we've been drawing
let's say here on this final output
layer you've got dog and cat well this
output layer is almost certain to have
just a sigmoid activation function and
what's gonna say is maybe dog is a point
seven nine and cat is a point two one
these two values are gonna add up to a
perfect 1.0 but we're gonna go with
whatever the largest value is so in this
case the neural network is you could say
79 percent confident that it's a dog 21
percent confidence a cat we're gonna say
we're gonna take the Arg max basically
and we're gonna say hmm we think it's a
dog all right now that we're all experts
on the concepts of neural networks let's
go ahead and build one you're gonna need
tensorflow so do a pip install - -
upgrade tensorflow you should be on
tensorflow version 1.1 or greater so one
thing you can do is import tensorflow
and then actually touch flow as TF and
then TF dot version will give you your
current version so mine is 1.10 now
let's go ahead and get started so the
first thing we're going to do is import
a data set we're going to use em nacelle
of data sets with machine learning it is
a dataset that consists of 28 by 28
sized images so it's like the resolution
images of handwritten digits 0 through 9
so it'll be like a 0 1 2 3 and so on and
it's a handwritten kind of unique image
so it's actually a picture we can graph
it soon enough so you can see it's
actually an image and the idea is to
feed through the pixel values to the
neural network and then have the neural
network output which number it actually
thinks that image is so that's our data
set and now what we want to do is unpack
that data set to training and testing
variables so this is a far more complex
operation when it's actually a data set
that you're kind of bringing in or that
you built or whatever for the sake of
this tutorial we want to use something
real basic like M inist
so we're gonna unpack it to X train Y
train and then we're going to do X test
Y test and that's gonna equal m n--
astana score data so that's gonna unpack
it into there now just to show you guys
what this is we're gonna use Matt plot
Lib you can pip install or just look at
it with me but we're gonna import
matplotlib pipe lot as a PLT and what
we're gonna do is peel TM show and we're
gonna do X train and we'll do the zero
width so one thing we could do just just
for the record let me just print so we
can you can see what we're talking about
here so this is just going to be an
array it'll be a multi-dimensional array
which is all a tensor is by the way so
this is this is here's your tensor right
okay so that's the the actual data that
we're gonna attempt to pass through our
neural network and just to show you if
we were to actually graph it and then do
a peel t touch show it's gonna be the
number and you can just excuse the color
it's definitely black and white it's a
single color it's a binary so one thing
we could say is the color map is equal
to P LTCM for color map binary Reap lot
it and there you go it's a it's not a
color image so anyways back to our
actual code up here once we have the
data one thing we want to do is is
normalize that data so again if I print
it out you can see it's data that seems
to vary from 0 to
looks like we have as high as 253 it's 0
to 255 4 pixel data so what we want to
do is scale this data or normalize it
but really what we're doing in this
normalization is scaling it so we're
going to just redefine X train and X
testing but it's gonna be TF caras dot
utils dot normalize and we're gonna pass
X train and it'll be on axis 1 and then
we're gonna copy paste and we're gonna
do the exact same thing for X test and
all this does let's just run that and
then we'll run this again and you can
see how the 5 has changed a little bit
looks like I got a little lighter and
then we come down here and we can see
the values here are now scaled between 0
and 1 and that just makes it easier for
a network to learn we don't have to do
this but at the end of this only
probably won't have time but if you want
on you know comment those lines out and
see how it effects the network it's it's
pretty significant ok so the next thing
we're gonna do now is actually build the
model so the model itself is gonna start
as TF karosta model's dot and then it's
going to be the sequential type of model
there's two types of models the
sequential is your your most common one
it's a feed-forward like the image we
drew so we're gonna use this sequential
model and then from here we can use this
like model dot add syntax so the first
layer is gonna be the input layer and
now right now our images are 28 by 28 in
this like multi-dimensional array we
don't want that we want them to be just
like flat if we were doing like a
confident or something like that we
might not want it to be flat but in this
case we definitely want to flatten it so
we could use that we could use like
numpy and reshape or we can actually use
one of the layers that's built into
chaos which is flattened so so we're
gonna do ad and what we're gonna add is
TF chaos layers dot flatten so one of
the reasons why you you want this to
actually be a layer type is like when
you have a convolutional neural network
a lot of times at the end of the
convolutional neural network there'll be
just like a densely connected layer and
so you need to flatten it before that
layer so it's it's it's used for more
than then the input layer we're just
use it for the input layer just to make
our lives easier so once we've got that
that's our input layer now we want to do
our hidden layers again we're going to
go with I think just two hidden layers
this isn't a complex problem to solve so
again we're going to use the model set
up model dot add syntax and we're gonna
add and in fact I think what I'm gonna
do is copy paste and then rather than a
flattened layer it's a dense layer in
the dense layer we're gonna pass a
couple parameters here so the first one
is gonna be how many units in the layer
so we're gonna use 128 units or 128
neurons in the layer then we're gonna
pass the activation function this is
like the function like I said like a
stepper function or a sigmoid function
what is gonna make that neuron fire or
sort of fire whatever so we're gonna use
TF tenon Lu for rectified linear this is
kind of the default go-to activation
function just use it as your default and
then later you can tweak it to see if
you can get better results but it's a
pretty good one to always fall back on
so we're gonna add the second one just
by copying and pasting again I'm gonna
add a final one and this is our output
layer which is still going to be a dense
layer it's not a hundred and twenty
eight your output layer will always if
it's in the case of classification
anyways it'll have your number of
classifications in our case that's ten
and the activation function we don't
want it to be rel you because we
actually this is like a probability
distribution so we want to use softmax
for a probability distribution so that
is our entire model we're done with
defining you know the the architecture I
guess of our model now what we need to
define is some parameters for the
training of the model so here we're
going to say model dot compile and in
here we're gonna pass some we're gonna
pass the optimizer that we want to use
we're gonna pass the loss metric which
loss you don't know we haven't really
talked about it loss is the degree of
error basically it's it's it's it's what
you got wrong so a normal network
doesn't actually attempt to optimize for
accuracy it doesn't try to maximize
accuracy it's always trying to minimize
loss so the way
that you calculate loss can make a huge
impact because it's it's what's the
losses relationship to your to your
accuracy op timer optimizer okay so the
optimizer that we're going to use is
going to be the Adam optimizer you could
use something this is basically it's
just your it's your it's the this is
like the most complex part of the entire
neural network so if you're familiar
with gradient descent you could pass
something like stochastic gradient
descent but the Adam optimizer kind of
like the rectified linear is the you
know just kind of the default go-to
optimizer you can use others there's
lots of them not lots but I don't know
ten or so in Karis anyways so anyways
there's other ones to go with Adam seems
to be the one that you should start with
for loss again there's many ways to
calculate loss probably the most popular
one is a categorical cross and true P or
some version of that and that in this
case we're gonna use sparse you can also
use binary like in the case of cats
versus dogs you probably use binary in
that case but you could you could just
kind of blanket categorical cross
entropy everything anyways then finally
what what are the metrics we want to
track like as we go and we're going to
just do accuracy accuracy okay so once
we have all this we're actually ready to
to train the model so to Train it's just
model that fit and then you're gonna
pass your what do you want to fit so X
train X test I'm sorry y ok X train
white rain and then epochs three total
brain for it okay let's go ahead and run
that and we should start to get some
training hopefully it doesn't crash me
as I'm recording but okay
looks good let's zoom out just slightly
so it looks a little better and we can
see actually our accuracy is always
already quite well our loss is also
still dropping so our accuracy should
still be improving and sure enough it is
awesome ok so we did pretty good we got
a 97% accuracy after only three epochs
which is pretty
good so once we have this we can this
was in sample so this might this is
always gonna really excite you but
what's really important to remember is
neural networks are great at fitting the
question is did they over fit so the
idea or the hope is that your model
actually generalized right it learned
patterns and in actual attributes to the
toe to what makes an eight ten what
makes a for rather than memorizing every
single sample you passed and you'd be
surprised how easily a model can just
memorize all the samples that you passed
to do very well so the next thing we
want to always do is calculate the
validation loss in the validation
accuracy and that is just model dot
evaluate evaluate X tests Y test and
then we'll go ahead and just print that
loss and Val accuracy and we can see
here the loss is almost point 11 and the
accuracy is at ninety six point five so
a little less than the one that we ended
on and the loss is quite a bit higher
relatively but you should expect that
you should expect your out-of-sample
accuracy to be slightly lower and your
loss to be slightly higher what you
definitely don't want to see is either
too close or it too much of a delta if
there's a huge Delta chances are you
probably already have over fit and you'd
want to like kind of dial it back a
little bit so that's basically
everything as far as the basics of Karos
and all that the only other things that
I wouldn't mind covering here is like if
you want to save a model and load a
model it's just model dot save and we
can save this as epoch num reader model
and then if you want to reload that
model we'll save it as it will call the
new underscore model that's going to be
equal to TF caras models dot load model
and it's this exact model name whoops
there we go
so that's our new model and then finally
if we wanted to make a prediction we
could say predictions equals new model
dot
dict and keep in mind predict always
takes a list this will get you a few
times for sure but anyways they'll take
a list and we'll do X underscore test
and then if we just print predictions
it's probably not gonna look too
friendly it's a little messy so what's
going on here these are all one hot
arrays and it's it these are our
probability distributions so what do we
do with these so I'm gonna use numpy you
can also use TF to arc max but it's an
abstract it's a tensor and we have to
pull it down we need a session and all
that it's just easier to import numpy
for at least for this tutorial here
import numpy as NP and then print for
example NP arg max or max let's do
predictions and let's just do the zero
width prediction okay it says it's a
seven so the prediction for X test zero
like the 0th index is it's a seven so
gee if only we had a way to draw it okay
we can definitely do this so we can do
PLT I'm sure and we're gonna do X test
zero with and then PLT dot show oh look
at that it's a seven okay so I think
that's basically all the things I would
want to show you guys as far as like
just a quick in you know QuickStart with
deep learning and Python and caris and
tensorflow
this just barely scratches the surface
there's so many things for us to do I
definitely plan to have at least one
more follow-up video covering things
like loading and outside datasets and
definitely some tents our board reading
the model understanding what's going on
and also what's going wrong because
that's eventually you know it's really
fun when we're doing tutorials and
problems or like already solved and we
know the answer it's very exciting but
in reality a lot of times you have to
dig to find the model that works with
your data so anyways that that's
definitely something we have to cover or
at least that you're gonna have to learn
somehow or other anyway that is all for
now if you got questions comments
concerns whatever feel free to leave
them below definitely check out red comm
slash are slash machine learning
the learned machine learning subreddit
you can come join our discord if you've
got questions that's just discord dot G
G slash cent decks will get you there
also special thanks to my most recent
channel members Daniel Jeffrey KB AB
Ajit H nur Newcastle geek fubá 44 Jason
and eight counts thank you guys so much
for your support without you guys I
couldn't do stuff like this so really
thank you anyways that's it for now more
to come
at some point until next time